welcome everybody hope everybody
celebrating thanksgiving has a uh good
thanksgiving planned um we will talk on
the bonus show today what are my plans
what are producer pat's plans producer
pat's plans are much more interesting
than mine uh he he will he will tell us
all about it a few stories that i did
want to go over with you guys this story
has gotten quite a bit of attention
multiple conservatives have quit fox
news over
what they say is the
increasing propaganda
particularly from tucker carlson and
it's interesting for what they say and
it's also interesting for what they
don't say and you'll see what i mean in
a moment
um this is about jonah goldberg and
steven hayes who have resigned from fox
news
protesting the irresponsible voice of
people like tucker carlson
hayes and goldberg announced sunday
night that they have resigned from fox
the pair wrote in a blog post for the
dispatch their online home that tucker
carlson's patriot purge propaganda film
was the last straw
fox news still does real reporting and
there are still responsible
conservatives providing valuable opinion
and analysis they wrote but the voices
of the responsible are being drowned out
by the irresponsible and carlson is the
case in point
cnn and other news outlets outlets
described how patriot purge is
disturbing evidence of right-wing
radicalization complete with january 6
denialism and paranoid descriptions of a
new war on terror targeting republicans
with references to guantanamo bay and
images of waterboarding now this is
interesting for a few different reasons
first of all the resignation came sunday
night
in advance of the one-hour propaganda
documentary produced by tucker carlson
about the kyle rittenhouse case
and the full interview that tucker
carlson did with kyle rittenhouse which
we covered yesterday which are
incredible propaganda pieces total and
full propaganda
lionizing and making a hero out of kyle
rittenhouse portraying him even as an
expert on things like prosecutorial
misconduct self-defense the fbi i mean
completely out of this world propaganda
so it's interesting that
it was the patriot purge thing that that
was sort of like the last straw
now it's interesting where these people
draw the line
goldberg and hayes are certainly more
along the lines of what we might call
i i hate to use the term like normal
conservatives but sort of more
traditional conservatives in the line of
like mitt romney and liz cheney in fact
mentioning liz cheney's interesting
because liz cheney even tweeted out a
thank you to goldberg and hayes for
calling out the lies on fox from that
patriot purge
propaganda piece
including the lies related to the 2020
election so that that's interesting
because that's clearly a contingent
but it's interesting where people draw
the line
because patriot purge is over the top
but fox has been radicalizing viewers
forever in many different ways and in
the months of uh uh the aftermath of the
2020 election
they were giving voice to absolutely
wacky conspiracy theorists with
completely fact-free views on the
election
and on and on and on so i don't want to
belittle the fact that goldberg and
hayes said this is as far as we're going
and this is too much and we've got to
leave that's fine
it's interesting because and it's
strange because the big picture of what
fox news is and what fox news does
really hasn't changed actually for a
very long time to be fair
uh tucker has been particularly off the
deep end lately with the anti-vac stuff
the written house stuff
etc so mentioning tucker is is sensible
that that certainly makes sense uh the
other thing about this is um
they're likely to be replaced with
wackier people and this is one of the
things where
when donald trump during kovid during
his um
calling it administration of cove it
doesn't even make sense when he was
president during the pandemic
and donald trump started slamming
anthony fauci and increasingly people
were asking why doesn't fouchy quit
why why stay in this situation
we said and maybe fauci also said i
don't remember i'm just kind of going
going from memory
that if he leaves he may well be
replaced with a yes person of some kind
rather than someone who's going to
insist on telling us what the science
actually is and along those same lines i
don't expect that goldberg and hayes are
going to be replaced on fox news by more
sensible people and that's always a
question that comes up
when someone has had enough with
something like fox news and they say i'm
taking myself out of it
often they get replaced with even more
radical voices and that well may happen
but we're going to watch it and it's
always interesting to see where do they
draw the line jonah goldberg and stephen
hayes drawing the line at the patriot
purge film from sunday
and
it's not a crazy place to draw the line
it was a completely whacked out film
um but it will be different for everyone
and of course that same film
many conspiracy theorists seeing it and
saying
now we have fox as well we got them
they're now with us and that's obviously
very very scary
your internet activity and data is being
observed by a variety of parties they're
selling your information they're
deciding what you can access don't let
it happen to you i use atlas vpn to keep
my internet traffic private from isps
tech platforms online marketers even
governments and atlas vpn keeps me
protected against hackers people
eavesdropping on networks to steal your
information
if i turn on atlas vpn before logging
into netflix hulu or amazon i can access
streaming content from other countries i
can even watch stuff from argentina like
soccer i use atlas vpn on all of my
devices you install it you turn it on
once and then you just forget about it
and enjoy your privacy you can read
online about why vpns are so important
to use every day really something you
should have and atlasvpn is having a
huge black friday sale giving you 86 off
comes out to like a dollar 39 a month
for a subscription plus you'll get three
months free just go to atlas v dot pn
slash pacman the link is down below